ah this is the blueprint to becoming a
millionaire and I'm going to walk you
through the levels to becoming one level
one is the fundamentals of wealth
creation and we're going to start with
what even is a millionaire it's someone
who's net worth excluding their primary
residence is an excess of a million do
assets minus liabilities for example
let's say you own a $1 million house and
you
owe $500,000 on it if you had nothing
else saved up in your bank account which
would hope that you did but let's just
say you had nothing else saved up in
your bank account then your net worth
would be 500k in this instance you would
not be a Millionaire right now let's
call this a $1 million house and then
you owed nothing on it your net worth
would be a million dollar now there's a
difference between having a liquid net
worth versus a net worth a liquid net
worth is assets that you can trade in
and out of so if I had million dollars
in cash in my bank account versus owning
assets that were worth a million dollars
those are different things and you might
be wondering how does Alex have any
Authority to speak on the subject I'll
tell you why I became a millionaire in
my early 20s I had my first cash million
in my bank account when I was 27 and I
cross $100 million in that worth by age
31 so I became a millionaire a 100 times
in a row so I can tell you how to do it
at least once and I've helped over a
hundred other people create Million
Dollar Plus net worths uh over my career
and those are just the ones that I know
about let alone all the people in our
community have done a lot better than
that and so we go to step two in this
little journey of ours which is equity
because there's two ways that you can
become a millionaire you can earn your
way there or you can own your way there
and the faster way is to own your way
there and that's what I'm going to walk
you
through so I'm going to walk you through
both examples of earning your way there
which is how I first thought it
was versus owning so if I want to earn
my way to a million then I'm going to
need to make $2 million over X period of
time and then divide that by two because
of taxes to get to my $1 million let's
say making $200,000 a year and I make
$200,000 a year for a decade that's
assuming that you saved 100% of your
income you'd be able to earn your way to
$1 million in liquid net worth on the
other hand you can own your way meaning
that you own assets either you know
which could be businesses or real estate
which are probably the two most common
assets that people own that are trying
to invest when I say invest when you are
an entrepreneur you are investing you're
just heavily indexed on one stock which
is your own let's say that I create a
business uh that gets to $250,000 per
year in some instances I might be able
to sell this company if it was truly
automated and had a a team of people
that worked without me needing it I
could sell this at probably a four times
multiple and this is again that would be
a very good multiple for a business that
is doing that kind of profit because
this is actually a small amount of
profit for when we're talking business
sales but that would get us to a $1
million net worth all right because we
own 100% of this business that makes
$250,000 a year in profit without us
working at all and we could sell that
for $1 million and so you can see the
difference here it's like okay well one
of these takes 10 years this one is just
how long does it take me to automate the
creation of $250,000 a year and so
what's interesting here is that almost
the actual income between the two is
almost identical but as soon as you
achieve it you almost already have the
the net worth because here time is
working against you because you have
taxes and you have your living expenses
that are cutting out of this every
single year whereas here you get the
multiplier without your living expenses
with time being an ally for you which
takes us to the next step on our
journey
don't diversify diversification is for
weenies diversification to quote Uncle
Warren is a hedge against ignorance you
only diversify if you don't know what
you're doing the more you know the less
risky it is I actually am approaching
diversification from a focus perspective
which is what's the one thing that
you're going to invest your most
valuable resource because when you're
early on you don't have that much money
so your most valuable resource isn't
your money it's your time and your
attention there's two ways we can
allocate it
V1 we do little allocations like this
I'm going to look at crypto I'm going to
look at day trading I'm going to look at
forx I'm going to look at flipping
houses I'm going to look at long-term
investing in real estates I'm going to
look into Airbnb I'm going to look into
starting an ATM business I'm going to
look at you get the idea right so let's
say this is you and this is your time
and attention that you have to pursue
any new opportunity so you say I need
seven income streams because the average
millionaire has seven income streams so
I'm going to spread myself thin between
seven different opportunities and while
I do that I'm going to be multitasking
trying to fill different cups at the
same time with different colors and I'm
somehow going to wait until one of these
things takes off right I have to see
which one of these will work but the
reality is it's not which of these ones
will work any of them could work if you
put the work in but you have to reach a
threshold once you get to the top the
extra cash starts spilling over and you
actually have a profitable opportunity
which one of these cups is closer to
spilling over you going in on one thing
or you spreading yourself between seven
and the reason that this myth continues
to proliferate is because it's
absolutely true that people who are the
wealthiest have multiple income streams
but what's not true is about how they
got there the wealthiest people in the
world go all in on one income stream and
they keep adding it up over and over and
over again until it overflows and then
once it overflows because they're making
so much money from their one opportunity
they then start diversifying back
between the other different ways but
they made their wealth focusing on one
thing and then they maintain their
wealth by Distributing it you don't make
money by by splitting your attention up
you make it by focusing on the one thing
that matters most B2 you say what do I
really like well I do have experience
doing this one thing and so I'm going to
ignore all of these other opportunities
and just go all in on one thing the
reason I'm such a big advocate of
focusing your attention on one thing is
that this is where you get
disproportionate returns because I think
it's very arrogant to think that your
10% of your attention where you're not
even that good at business to begin with
spread between 10 things is somehow
going to compete against somebody who's
putting all of their effort on one thing
but here's the fallacy that most people
who are starting out don't get they
think I'm going to try all of them and
see which one works out or rather I'm
going to try to start multiple things
and see which one takes off but the
reality is that all of them could take
off or none of them could take off but
it's solely based on which one you work
on so it's not which one will work it's
which one will you work on you want to
go as fast as possible through the I
have no idea what I'm doing phas so you
can get to the I do know what I'm doing
faas and I understand the risks that are
associated with this and that's why I
don't want to diversify because I
actually get outsize returns here
there's five stages that you go through
as an entrepreneur when you're
considering a new opportunity phase
one is called uninformed optimism this
is where you are uninformed but you're
like man this opportunity sounds so
great look at all these people making
all this money and so then you dive in
and then you get to something called
informed pessimism you're like oh wow
this isn't as easy as I thought there's
all these other things that they didn't
talk about in this ad or in this
highlight reel that they show me on this
YouTube short about this person that
made $1,000 a day going from nothing
from her home right so then what happens
next is you keep working on it and then
you get into the valley of
Despair sad face sad face this is where
most people quit and this is what most
people do now dot dot dot dot dot dot
dot dot dot they find another one of
these things to get into and they go all
the way over back here because the think
oh no this one has doooo on this side of
the fence so I'm going to go to the
other side of the fence where the grass
is green but what they don't realize is
when they get into that side it's
completely made of manure and that's why
the grass is so green right there's poo
on both sides you just didn't know about
it until you got there all right and so
what happens is people keep repeating
the cycle over and over and over again
and they never make progress and so
here's the thing is that when you do
find something that you're like you know
what I kind of like this okay this is
harder than I originally thought I need
to keep learning wow this is actually
really hard there's a lot more pieces to
this than I understood at the beginning
I guess this is why everyone isn't rich
and then something magic happens you
then start to have informed optimism you
now start to realize you've wrapped your
arms around whatever the opportunity is
or whatever thing you're pursuing and
you're like okay I haven't gotten there
yet but I understand the math I
understand the process of getting where
I am to where I'm trying to go and
ultimately this is what I'm trying to do
with this blueprint for you is it if I
can help you tackle as much of this or
at least compress the time that it takes
you get here that's a big victory for me
and then you finally get to the Final
Phase which is achievement which is you
actually accomplish externally what you
set out to and most newbies fall out
between here and here and then start
this process over again so most people
only relive this over and over and over
again without ever making it to
here which then naturally leads you to
here because then you have no desire to
diversify because you now get it and
what do you do when your hair you reset
the you reset the Target and you say
this is where I want to go next and
because you've been through this process
once you understand that you know what
me going after this 10 times bigger girl
sounds amazing I'm going to find out
there's some stuff that sucks there's
going to be a period where it's going to
really suck and it's going to feel
hopeless cuz I don't see how how to get
through it I'm going to keep chugging
and then understand how to get there and
then I'm going to get there I'm going to
repeat the process so now we go to the
last part of level one of becoming a
millionaire
the long
game if I told you to build the tallest
tower you possibly could in 10 seconds
here's what you might do
boom 5
4 3
2 one time right now imagine I told you
to build the tallest building you
possibly could in 10 days you would
probably say you know what I can
probably get some more boxes how flimsy
is is this right like how stable is this
do you think this is going to last a
long time probably not so I might build
it piece by piece from the ground up
with more stable bricks from day one and
I would keep doing it this way right and
I'd keep adding and keep adding and keep
adding and then when 10 days came I
might be five stories high and so the
reason this is such an important frame
shift for people is that the fact that
they're in a rush causes them to build
the thing they want to build differently
the fastest way to get to this tall is
to build it the exact way I did earlier
stack it end to end up to this point but
if I then said I need you to build
something that's 10 stories tall you
would never get there and what happens
is people get stuck right they get stuck
at this
level and they can't add another one on
top and they stay here and they're like
why can't I get my million doll business
to $10 million and it's because you
built it wrong to begin with and so as
much as this sounds painful sometimes
the fastest way to to get to 10 million
is to start back at zero and build it
right to begin with I talk so much about
long game about making sure that you're
building it the right way because this
thing is never going to last and so the
hardest thing about building something
right is that in the beginning you need
to have something to sell need your
amazing valuable thing and then that's a
megaphone it's terrible but then you
need to advertise it to let people know
about stuff and
then you start making sales but the
problem is that people get to this point
and then think oh I need to do more
marketing and sales right because that's
what made me money but the problem is
the more you market and sale the more
people actually find out that this is
not a gift and this is actually a big
pile of and so what happens is now
you've got people who buy this thing and
tell their friends this thing stinks and
then over time it becomes more and more
expensive for you to advertise
because your reputation stinks and so
the right way to build it is to
understand that you you have to build
the thing first and then you got to let
people know about it but then you don't
crank on this you keep fixing this thing
until this guy becomes a happy
camper and tells his friends and until
that happens you keep making this thing
better and this is the same thing as if
I did this and just kept gassing it
that's me vertically building the tower
and then reaching a Max that I can't go
past anymore versus building it so that
I get people to say wow this thing's
amazing and so then they also tell
people for me so that when I get to that
point I actually built it with a huge
base of foundation and I can keep
stacking on top of it and that's the
difference in terms of mindset and
perspective of how you actually build
something that's going to last and then
along the way with your team and the
people that you hire rather than saying
hey I just need a body in the seat I
just need a person to do this thing
you're like who here has talent and I
might interview 20 people for one role
rather than three so I get the right
person if you feel stuck all the time
and you can't make progress you usually
need to go back to the beginning and
realize that you built a vertical
business that had no Foundation to begin
with and now we have our foundation
built for level one of wealth creation
level two is all about the actual
tactics of getting to making your first
million and it starts with finding a
hungry crowd let me explain what I mean
by find a hungry crowd this guy started
a business selling hot dogs and he was
given One Wish from a genie of what
competitive Advantage he would be able
to have the first thought he had was
like maybe I'll make my hot dogs cheaper
the genie shook his head and was like no
he's like hm what if I made my hot dogss
taste better and then Genie said no
don't waste your wish on that maybe I'll
just make mine the fastest cooking so I
can serve the hot dogs faster the genie
said that's not what you want to waste
your wish on the genie looked at him
holding the hot dogs in buns in hand and
said it's not about the hot dogs if you
want to build an amazing business you
want to put your hot dog stand on the
best corner in front of a starving crowd
because if your hot dog stand is on the
corner it doesn't matter how cheap they
are how good they taste how fast they
cook the moment that hungry crowd walks
out and sees your hot dog stand you're
going to sell it every time so right off
the bat I want to talk about two key
Concepts when it comes to finding a
hungry crowd one is that we have to
understand that the market is always
going to be the strongest variable in
how much money you make right if you're
selling toilet paper during coid you're
going to sell out right because it
didn't matter how good your toilet paper
was there was a starving crowd and so
Supply demand which is one of the
reasons that we have it as our logo it
is the strongest force in all of
economics and business it is the core
thing that everything else is built on
and so you have to understand that the
market is number one if I was trying to
sell services to newspaper companies
well newspaper companies are decreasing
by 25% per year compounding negatively
in the wrong direction the next lever on
this is the offer that you give people
right if you have a superior offer then
if you're in a normal Market that'll be
the next lever that you have if I say
hey start for free and I only get paid
if you get some sort of result and it's
a truly free lowrisk amazing value and
you get results tomorrow offer then
you're going to sell 10 times 100 times
more than than someone who just has like
a you pay me and maybe you get results
and maybe you don't type of service or
product the final thing is your ability
to persuade ideally go after a really
big Market with an amazing offer and be
a hell of a Persuader but the thing is
is you can be terrible at persuading and
have a terrible offer and say you can
only buy my toilet paper in 80 roll
chunks or I'm not going to sell it to
you and still sell out during Co but if
it's not Co then it's how can I make the
toilet paper offer that I have
significantly more compelling and if all
the toilet paper offers look the same
then it just comes down to how well I
can persuade people to buy mine that's
concept one when it comes to finding a
100 Crow concept two is the four things
that I look for when I'm actually trying
to find that market number one is I want
people who are in pain you want to make
sure that the people that you were
selling to are in desperate need they
don't want but must have the thing that
you were selling the second is that they
must have the ability to buy so
purchasing power so a friend of mine had
a business where he helped people who
are unemployed fix their resumés so that
they could get a job now you might be
like oh wow tons of pain absolutely but
the problem was he kept trying to grow
this business and he couldn't grow it
because they were all broke cuz they
didn't have a job the third factor that
I look for is easy to Target because at
the end of the day even if you have
somebody using lots of pain who can buy
your thing if you can never find them it
doesn't matter because they're never
going to buy your things they'll never
know you exist and so if I have the
choice between two different
marketplaces and one of them is like
nurses incredibly easy to find or
something that is way harder to find
like psychedelic Aztecs in you know
Croatia way harder to Target and you
know what they might have a huge pain
and lots of purchasing power to buy my
thing but if I can't find them it's
irrelevant the fourth point you want to
have is that you have a growing market
now I gave the example earlier about the
newspapers right so believe it or not a
good friend of mine actually had a
business that sell a REV share model to
newspaper so he was an amazingly
persuasive guy he had an amazing offer
off which is zero risk he just said like
let me get a percentage of the revenue
that I bring to you all right so these
two things were completely maxed out but
he couldn't figure out why his company
wasn't growing every year he was beating
his competitors and gaining more
customers than they were but still
slipping away in terms of his ability to
grow and it was because the entire
Marketplace as a whole was shrinking and
so you want to make sure that you have
all four of these things you can't just
have three of them or two of them or one
of them you need to have all four and so
when you're thinking about what thing
you want to sell start with who you want
to sell it to so you have your hungry
crowd now what do you do one Avatar one
product one channel this is the simplest
formula to getting $2 million plus all
you have to do is find one person that
you want to help it's just making sure
that you're very clear on the one very
specific person that you are going to
help that is the Avatar the next thing
is you want to give them one product and
the reason I say it's one product is
that a lot of people over complicate
their businesses too early they're like
man if I want to double my business I
should sell them three things right and
then I'll get them to buy more stuff but
the thing is is that if you're under a
million dollars you're just adding a ton
of complexity when you don't even have
that many customers and so most times
you'd be better served sticking with the
one thing that you're selling and saying
how can I sell three times as many of
the exact same person and that becomes
the problem that you solve but most
people get confronted with these issues
and then go for the easy route and again
this is like that building where you can
add something on top really quickly but
it doesn't create the skyscraper that
you want instead you want think how can
I do more the third variable here is
channel now it doesn't matter what
channel you're currently acquire
customers on you can hit a Million
Dollar Plus on literally any channel
that you advertise on without going onto
new channels so if you do Outreach is
then you reach out to people 10 to one
to get customers whether that's cold
calls cold emails DMS you can expand and
continue to get more customers with that
one channel if you post content you can
keep posting content on whatever Channel
you're on and just do it better post
more cont content post better content
and by doing so you increase the amount
of customers still with only one
money-making product or let's say you're
running ads obviously if you're running
ads you can just spend more money on the
ads provided you're doing it profitably
and if you can't expand past a million
dollars a year profitably with paid ads
you have a business problem or you have
a pricing problem you don't actually
need to add another Channel because then
it again complicates your business
because you're like okay well I'm
currently doing you know 500,000 a year
on YouTube you know what I'm going to do
you might think oh I'm I'm going to
start doing cold emails right as my next
way of getting customers well that
majorly complicates your business when
you're this early on now you might be
thinking wait shouldn't I have diversity
of of how you acquire customers I
thought you said that was a good idea it
is but you're so small it doesn't matter
yet because you're not looking at a
potential acquirer who's going to try
and look to decrease risk for you you
just need to get better at doing the one
thing that you do well cuz you're really
probably not that good yet and as
terrible as that may sound it's probably
real all right and so the fastest way to
get to the million is to build it right
from the get-go and not over complicate
your business which means you pick one
Avatar one product and one channel that
you focus on until you get there so now
we go back to our tactics of building
our first million dollars the next thing
at level two is our offer now I wrote an
entire book on this thing $100 million
offers it answers the question what
should I sell and it's because that's
the most common question that I get
asked every single day for people who
trying to start a business which makes
sense what am I supposed to sell so I
call this the value equation now
fundamentally you've probably heard all
over the Internet you need to provide
value you got to give value right but
the question is what is value and after
doing a lot of studying of figuring this
out between our portfolio companies it
actually comes down to four variables
variable number one is the dream outcome
what the dream outcome is for whoever
the prospect that you pick is the way
that you can compare two different dream
outcomes is how much more valuable they
think one outcome is versus another if I
were to talk to a 30-year-old man and
say hey I can help you lose weight or I
can make you a millionaire most guys
would value you being a millionaire more
than let's say being handsome there are
different outcomes that people will
ascribe different values to and that's
just a very extreme example well let's
use the weight loss example and let's
switch it to women if I have one ebook
that helps someone lose weight and then
I've got a one-onone personal training
program that have someone lose weight
it's the same dream outcome so then what
then determines which one is more
valuable because the ebook might be 50
bucks and be overpriced and the personal
training might be $5,000 and be
underpriced how can you make that
discrepancy because there's more value
let me explain the next one is perceived
likelihood of achievement meaning when I
buy How likely do I think I will get
what I want through buying if I buy a
$50 ebook on good meals that I can cook
that are healthy maybe I'll get some
food that I might like in here and I can
feel a little better about myself but
they don't realistically think that
they're going to all of a sudden
transform their entire body from a $50
ebook now if you sign up for personal
training for a year you probably have a
way bigger perceived likelihood of
achievement and so you value it higher
now both of these elements the dream
outcome and the perceived likelihood of
achievement are the things that you want
to
increase in your communication with a
prospect you're saying it's really
really likely that you're going to get
this thing that you really really want
the next two variables of the equation
are the painful side of the equation
which is what does someone have to give
up in order to get it so the first thing
that we have is time and there's two
elements of time there's micro and macro
micro is how long is this going to take
every day there's a certain amount of
time that's going to take on the micro
for them to experience the result right
so if I'm talking about the lady who's
doing personal training she might have
to go to the gym three times a week
that's going to take time she might have
to prepare food that's going to take
time that's on the micro level on the
macro level how long is she going to
have to do these micro commitments in
order to get the macro result that she
wants she might have to lose 50 lbs and
it might take her 18 months so macro the
goal is I want this to be as little as
possible micro time and I want this to
be as short as possible on the macro so
that when I say hey you're going to get
the dream body you want you absolutely
know that you're going to get it and
it's it's going to happen really really
fast so the next thing is effort and
sacrifice effort is what you have to
start doing that you weren't doing that
you don't want to do as a result of the
purchase sacrifice are things that you
have to stop doing that you wish you
could do but can't do anymore as a
result of the purchase and so for our
lovely young lady she's going to have to
sacrifice margarit a Mondays and taco
Tuesdays she's no longer going to be
able to get to do that even though she
wants to do that she's G to have to
sacrifice sleeping in on the weekends
and she's going to have to start waking
up early and working out and eating food
that she doesn't like and so effort and
sacrifice tend to be dual sides of the
same coin whatever you have to start
doing you typically have to stop doing
something else the top side we try and
increase the bottom
side we try and decrease we want to get
it to zero because if you think about
this in a hypothetical extreme the
perfect offer that would have the
absolute most value would be the biggest
most compelling dream you can possibly
imagine that you're absolutely
guaranteed to get instantly with no
effort so if I said you can click a
button on my website and then look down
at your abs and then have a six-pack
that would be the hypothetical extreme
value now people can get that through
personal training changing their diet
and waiting 12 months but because of
this the value is significantly
decreased because there are costs
associated understanding all four of
these variables is how you craft offers
that get people to say yes and give you
money because often times the most
expensive part of the offer that you
have isn't the money it's the other
things that they have to start doing as
a result of the purchase those are
called hidden costs if I have a
marketing agency okay and I do content
for people all right and when I start
doing content I say okay it's going to
take us 60 days to ramp up we're going
to start having two calls a week for an
hour you're going to have to fly out to
my studio and we're going to record and
it's going to take 60 days before you're
going to start seeing any kind of
traction imagine that offer comp
compared to somebody who says you don't
need to do anything I can just draw
stuff on my own immediately start
posting and your phone's going to ring
today we shoot which one's more valuable
it's still the same core services but
how we wrap them make them probably 10
times more valuable than they were
before and that's why I understand these
variables and making the right offer is
so compelling on your road to your first
million and the reason this was my first
book Is that offers is about strategy
offers is one of the largest levers that
you can pull with any business because
it actually affects all departments when
you change the offer it changes how you
Market when you change the offer it
changes the sales script the sales
process when you change the offer it
changes what you deliver it literally
affects everything and so for us we
always try and nail this with our
portfolio companies at acquisition.
comom to be clear we don't sell coaching
we invest in businesses and buy them and
for context our average portfolio
company over the first 12 months 1.8x is
revenue and 3.01 X's profit and over
their first 24 months they 2.8 8X
revenue and 4.7x profit meaning that
they disproportionately drop the
increase in Revenue to their bottom line
because we make sure that the thing that
we are selling is as valuable as humanly
possible so the next on our journey of
wealth and riches and glory and status
and all things amazing is marketing and
sales and if you think about this from a
sequence perspective you have to make
the thing and then you have to promote
the thing now the making the thing is
$100 million offers which should I sell
the next question is who should I sell
it to AKA getting leads and you get
leads through advertising which is the
concept of my second book $100 million
leads and then you get them to buy but
the thing that people mess up is that
they then think okay I'm going to do
more of that but what you actually need
to do next is you go back to here and
you fix the product and keep making it
better and then you promote it more and
then you come back and fix the product
and make it better and it becomes this
virtuous cycle so if we need to
understand how to Market and sell then
it means that you have to have one
advertising method there are eight ways
you can advertise there's four that you
can do and then there's four that other
people can do for you you can do warm
Outreach which is reaching out one to
one to your friends you can post content
one to many but to people who know you
you can run paid ads which is doing one
to many to strangers or you can do one
to one to strangers which is cold
Outreach and if you're like man no one's
buying my thing I can guarantee you that
you're not doing enough of these core
four period that's it because these are
the only four things that you can do to
advertise the next next thing is that
you can get referrals from customers
which are lead Getters next you can have
employees who help do the core 4 for you
you can have agencies who run the core
for for you make content for you do
Outreach for you all of those things you
can hire another business to help you
with and then finally you've got
Affiliates which some people call
influencers some people call
endorsements but it's somebody who
already has an audience already has a
business and that you compensate in some
way to do the advertising for you the
core for to let other people know about
your stuff these are the eight ways that
you can advertise anything to anyone and
the nice thing is when you're starting
out for your first million just pick one
once you pick the advertising method
that you want and let's say you're using
lead Getters you have to learn one of
the core four to then get lead Getters
and that's okay that's fine that's part
of business these will always give you
more leverage than the first four and
that's okay but you have to start with
these first so let's assume that you're
just going to stick to the core four in
the beginning because you're like I
don't want to involve other parties
which I recommend especially if you're
starting out and you're like you know
what I'm going to post content that's
what you're going to do that's your your
method all right now you're going to
have all these people who like your
posts comment on your posts DM you
personally when you make content that
they find compelling or interesting and
say hey I love your help on whatever
this thing is then you transition into
sales now it's so important for Founders
who are starting a company to be
integrally involved in both of these
processes the reason you want the
founder to be integrally involved in the
beginning is one it's cheaper and
especially when you have less cash that
makes sense two these are skills that
you're going to that are going to be
required for you to succeed over the
long so you're going to want to
understand them at a tactical level
because when you bring someone else in
in the future these lead Getters whether
it's employees agencies Affiliates or
whatever you can teach them the right
way to do it and when they say hey
that's not possible you be like no it is
let me show you how and then you have a
litus test of who's legit and who's not
who's going to help you on your journey
whether you're hiring them or you're
incentivizing them it works the same
when it comes to the sales side we want
to get into a choreograph process
knowing what step one through letter Z
of the process looks like to get someone
from I think this might be interesting
to giving you money but if you don't
know what you're doing first you have to
throw stuff on the wall and see what
sticks and a lot of it's just going to
be your gut in the beginning and figure
out whoop that didn't work whoop that
didn't oh that one actually got a
response all right that's step two and
you keep trying until you get to step
three and then you keep trying until you
get to step four until eventually
somebody gives you money and then you
backtrack and say what happened to this
person that do these steps great now I'm
going to try and recreate that as many
times as I can and then that becomes
your process and that process repeats at
each micro level too because that might
be three or four steps to get to the
conversation where someone might give
you money and then what do you do in
that conversation well when I ask this
question first and this question second
and this question third it's more likely
that they ultimately buy and so if you
don't follow a script in the beginning
you better make one because if you're
going to eventually get out of sales
which you should if you want to scale
then you're going to be able to teach
somebody else how to sell too and one of
the biggest issues early on is that the
founder is the most convicted about the
product and you should be it's your
company but people who come after you
are never going to be as charismatic or
as convicted in the thing that you have
as you are which means you need to
follow a process to maximize the likely
that the prospects that they speak with
ultimately purchase the next level in
our blueprint or journey to wealth the
mountain of Mordor and by Mordor I mean
more money is paying yourself how much
should you pay yourself when should you
pay yourself of all the topics we're
going to talk about today this is
probably the most subjective and the
reason for that is because it underlines
one key concept that is 100% personal
which is risk tolerance which is how
much risk are are you willing to take
individually one of the regrets that I
have earlier on as I continued to double
down on my gym chain was that I took all
the profit from each gym and I kept
putting it into the next gym and I
basically took nothing out for the
entire time now that's super risky I was
living on nothing living cheap I was
eating cheap I had a cash car that I
owned outright and I just put everything
I had spend every hour of my day growing
my business eventually though I ended up
losing all the money from selling all my
gyms and was left with nothing and if I
had taken out some cash during that
period of time I would have had to
benefits benefit number one is that when
you really try and take out cash flow
from the business you'd be amazed at how
much cash flow just magically appears
and so I like having bank account PRS be
a good personal goal for every
entrepreneur even if the increment that
increasing is small it does two things
one it forces you to take cash out of
the business so it forces cash flow the
second is that it forces you to decrease
your spending personally and I have a
strong belief that as you're coming up
learning the discipline to spend less if
you increase the cash for that you take
out of the business and you spend less
over time then your bank account has
nowhere to go but up and I can promise
you that when you have a very full bank
account business decisions become less
stressful and when you make less
stressed decisions you make better
decisions I do believe in taking some
money out of the business along the way
because let's be real you're going to
live a long life and then you're going
to die and if you double down every
single minute until the day that you
died you'd build the most Enterprise
Value you live a really shitty life so
at some point you have to balance the
investment versus consumption of life
itself or the fruit of your labor that
is why I'm a Believer in at least
allocating a certain percentage of the
cash flow from the business to you
personally a healthy way of thinking
about this that we have for some of our
uh heavy Capital intensive businesses
meaning like brick and mortar chains
which is one of the biggest parts of our
portfolio this is one back of napkin way
that you can use 33% goes to you 30%
goes to growth which is new
locations and then this is rainy day
this is Cash reserves for the business
cash reserves for you and this is for
new location another way of doing it is
something called a watermark we know
that we need to grow two locations and
this is a proxy it doesn't have to be
two locations you could be hiring two
people hiring two reps it doesn't matter
two more developers if you're a software
company it works the same two more per
month cost $ X we have y profit so all
we do is we say whatever the profit is
at the end of the month we subtract this
and then we have a watermark above which
we always leave in the account and then
everything
else we distribute this cash flow that's
a different way of doing it this is a
little bit more aggressive if you want
to maintain a certain growth rate this
one is a little bit more flexible it
really depends on you and your tolerance
for risk and that's one one thing that
I'd say I pride myself on in terms of
our ability to help portfolio companies
and newer Founders who are creating
their first kind of generational wealth
is these are hard conversations to have
and a really important conversation to
have and you want somebody who isn't a
financial adviser who's trying to get
you to take as much cash out so that
they can invest and get their 1% fee you
want somebody's on the same side of the
tables You' be like I get where you're
at I can see where your wealth is and
also sees over the next 24 36 60 months
what it looks like for us to just have
that one big bloop so you never have to
work again we're now approaching the
second level the Pinnacle of our second
level which is setting goals and I think
this is a really disinterested topic
most people think like oh I need smart
goals or specific go B I'll show you how
I do that all right so rather than
focusing on outcomes we focus on
activities so the goal shouldn't be what
happens but the goal should be what we
do I I had a buddy of mine they started
doing 10 grand a month 20 grand a month
30 grand a month and then he would fall
off and I was like why do you keep
falling off he's said well I make the
money and I hit my goal so then I like
ease off the gas p and I said it's
because you're defining your goals the
wrong way I see you as not hitting your
goal every time you're not doing the
activities and so I said make the
activities the goal and then you'll hit
it every time and more and so then he
flipped how he saw his own success into
simply at the end of the day did he do
all the things that he said he was going
to do at the beginning of the day and
then you can actually control your
inputs because
inputs are what
Drive outputs don't make the goal
outputs say what am I going to do that
would be unreasonable that I don't hit
these outputs so for example my inputs
might be and this is one of my favorite
ways we're thinking about like
advertising is something that I call the
rule of
100 so the rule of 100 simply states
that if you do 100 primary actions over
100 days you'll usually get the first
result that you ultimately want now you
hook people by saying you're going to
get the first result you want but the
key point is that you're doing 100
actions and one of my little monitors
that I would share with you is count in
hundreds all right so when a lot of
people are like man I did the thing how
many hundreds did you do if I was doing
more reach outs I'd say cool reach out
to 100 friends a day if I'm doing cold
reach outs i' say cool reach out to 100
people a day if I'm making content cool
make 100 minutes of content every day if
I'm running ads i' say run $100 a day
and each of those are activities that we
can say these things will Drive these
outputs they make that the goal and so
at the end of the day you can say yes I
did it or no I didn't do it not did I
make a sale because no matter what even
if you didn't make a sale today you
should still do your 100 inputs so that
you can make two sales tomorrow so the
second con I'm going to talk to you
about when it comes to goals is how we
actually set goals for portfolio
companies and it's not the way that you
think but it is something that you're
going to recognize because we actually
use the scientific method and here's how
it works four simple boxes one is what
problem are we try to solve a lot of
times we spend the most time on this
part of this because a lot of times
people are like oh I think we need to
redo our logo why what is that going to
accomplish what constraint are we
alleviating right because for us we back
our goals into the constraints of the
business because let's say that
conversion rate on our homepage is not a
problem well then why do we need to
redesign the logo oh we don't one of my
favorite ways to solve problems is
decide they not a problem to begin with
so this is column number one which is
what problem we're solving the second is
what's our hypothesis which is an if the
end statement X then y so what that
means is I say my hypothesis is if our
website is low conversion that's the
problem that we're solving my hypothesis
is that if we redesign the website we
will then get increased conversions and
then all we have to do is say how do we
measure X and Y how do I measure that we
redesign it I could say yes or no I did
it or I could say that we hold a split
test every Monday that we run over the
quarter that would be the X that's
something I can say yes or no we did and
then why my conversion rate let's say
we're at
10% and then I would say is it greater
than
10% yes or no and then finally the last
thing is did we do
it and then did it work we figure out
the problem we're solving we figure out
what our hypothesis is to solve it we
determine how we're going to measure
whether or not we did or whether or not
it happened and then we say did did we
do the thing and then did it happen
because we could not do the thing and
then it wouldn't matter and we'd have to
repeat it later and solve the problem
why are we not doing this thing but if
we did do the thing then either it
improved it or maybe we redesigned the
website and the conversion rate didn't
improve so either that might not be the
constraint or hypothesis was wrong and
so this allows you to iteratively
improve the business so we covered the
fundamentals of wealth creation and we
talked about how to create our first mil
and now we've got it and now level three
we're going to talk about stay rich and
get even
richer getting rich once so uh one of my
mentors uh was ex Goldman Sachs and
Chloe one of his mentors at Golden Sachs
told him you should only have to get
rich once and I heard that saying it's
really stuck with me is if you play the
game right you should only have to play
it once and then after that you should
be paying with house money the whole
time and never take bets that you would
lose the farm over in other words never
B the Empire on a pot of gold if this is
the very first pass in $100 Milli offers
outside returns often come from betting
against conventional wisdom and
conventional wisdom is usually right
given a 10% chance of 100 times payoff
you should take that bet every time for
you're still going to be wrong nine
times out of 10 we all know that if you
swing for the fences you're going to
strike out a lot but you're also going
to hit some home runs the difference
between baseball and business however is
that baseball has a truncated outcome
distribution when you swing no matter
how well you connect with the ball the
most RS you can get is four in business
every once in a while when you step off
to the plate you can score 1,000 runs
this longtail distribution of returns is
why it's important to be bold Big
Winners pay for so many experiments
that's from Jeff BOS so if you do hit it
out of the park you shouldn't want to
have to bet everything on it again to
keep staying Rich when you get that one
winning bet or that one winning ball
that comes and you knock it out of the
park you shouldn't you should be able to
win for good and so that's why one of my
favorite saying when it comes to wealth
building is that fortunes are created
through taking huge risk with small
amounts of money but for fortunes are
preserved by taking small risks with
lots of money so we talked about why you
should only have to car which once and
if you are going to swing for the fences
you still need to be very sure that once
you hit it you never bend it all on
black again which then leads us actually
to our next one people sobody to explain
a concept called the quad marketing
calendar all right so you think about
this as internal and external to your
business now you got prospects on this
side we got customers candidates we got
employees and so you actually need to be
Marketing in all four directions at all
times most people spend all their time
advertising here they say okay I'm going
to spend all my resources advertising to
get prospects and then they convert
those prospects over this money line and
then turn those prospects into customers
but the problem is if you own only
advertis in this direction who's going
to
deliver the thing to these customers
well you need employees which means that
you also need to be advertising to get
candidates to turn into employees and so
this is ultimately the dual-sided nature
of advertising because as you grow the
left side you need to also grow the
right side if you want to continue to
get these customers to buy again and
again and again then we also need to
advertise in this direction to the
customers to get them to buy again and
again so we advertise your prospects any
customers we advertise to get customers
to become repeat customers we advertise
the candidates to turn them into
employees and we advertise the employees
to get them more engaged and to keep
them engaged and and keep educating them
so they can Ascend up and provide even
more value to our customers UL the
Enterprise Value company so if you ever
feel like you're a genius with 1 th000
hands it usually you're really good at
advertising and turning prospects into
customers right but you're really bad
and turning candid into employees and
then training employees to get to become
even better and so the more you
advertise here the more you feel like
you have to do because you have no one
else helping you out so let's say we've
got our genius scenario we've got an
Enterprise scenario so if you're the
genius with 1 th000 hands right and
you're making $5 million Top Line and $2
million of income every year you make $2
million which adds a million after taxes
to your net worth this is a while like
before right but here's the difference
between the example I'm explain now what
I was talking about before in this
instance you add the million dollars to
your
business but you also have a probably
$10 million asset as a business if this
thing truly rubs value EV is short for
Enterprise Value so there is no
Enterprise Value here because it's just
a genius with 1,000 hands you're just
doing with a th000 helpers here you own
something that provides value to a group
of customers that you can sell to
somebody else because if if you require
no work in order to provide the value it
means it require someone else to do no
work to provide the value which means it
becomes a more valuable asset and so if
I took a business for genius with a
th000 hands making $2 million a year and
I didn't increase the revenue and I
didn't even increase the profit but I
simply remove the genius and make the
structure of the business genius the
people who work inside of it and the
processes the systems that they follow
genius then I add $1 million the net
worth of the person who owns it and so
one of the fastest ways to create wealth
is make the thing that you have reliable
is to make it risk-free and make sure
that it will last and so even if it took
you two years to do that for you to get
$10 million of Enterprise Value or or
net worth gain you'd have to make $20
million of income to get to that same 10
million but meanwhile while you're
building it you're still also making
money in this scenario which is what we
basically do for the majority of
businesses that we have at acquisition.
is that we often take business as doing
2 million 3 4 5 Etc and then then take
them to this side and say hey let me
show you what looks like at
10 with a 7x multiple and so now you go
from a one or2 or $3 million net worth
to a $70 million net worth and that is
how you get wealthy this is how you get
rich now I want to be clear you can
absolutely get to million a year in
profit with not a lot of people or even
just on your own because with the
increas of AI and Automation and things
like that like we're going to see more
big companies with fewer and fewer head
count but until the day until General AI
comes in and just crushes everyone
people are still required to get to
where you want to go so if you want to
not just make a million bucks or a
couple million bucks and you want to get
to 10 20 50 $100 million and Beyond you
got to get the people side right and now
we go to the reputation side ooh a fun
one imagine all these flowers as
different life experiences that you've
gone through if you look at them all
here this isn't a bouquet this is just a
lot of r things put together now when we
do this and we combine them
all we now have something much closer to
a bouquet and when you put all of your
personal life experiences and your
skills and your character traits
together you create a bouquet and in
other words you create a reputation but
a bouquet doesn't really exist all we
did was we Associated things that were
separate and then we put them together
and so you can strengthen your
reputation by putting more and similar
types of experiences together so you're
like oh he's got a strong interest in
this thing now if every single one of
these would be different and some of
these were weeds it would be a lot
harder to understand what is the point
of this thing and let's say that you had
a drunk driving accident right all of a
sudden how different does this bouquet
look which shows you how one negative
experience in your life can actually
affect how people see the rest of
everything else and so when we're
thinking about brand or building a
reputation I like to think of as what
flowers do I want in my bouquet and
which things am I ultimately trying to
emphasize or not include at all and what
associations are going to be ones that
strengthen this and width are going to
be ones that break it apart so
reputation is a different word for
saying what a brand is and a brand is
simply an association between something
you know and something you don't know
when we're building a brand you want to
associate all the things that you want
someone to think about you with the
thing that they don't know yet which is
you now for me the more my personal
brand has grown the more I have
transposed acquisition. comom
association with me and so now when my
team goes out to the airport and is
wearing a hat that says acquisition.
comom people are like dude can I buy
that hat from you because they've gotten
value for my videos in my books they see
an association with that value and they
want to pay for it but if this just had
a random shape on it they would have no
desire to pay 50 if this actually
happened one my director of HR the
airport and a random person came up was
like can I pay you $100 for the hat and
she said no obviously because that's not
how our brand Works got to earn it so
the idea is that that is fundamentally
how braiding works if I'm Louis Vuitton
right I'm going to do the world's worst
Louis Vuitton symol right if I'm Louis
Vuitton what do I do I get Kim
Kardashian to wear my clothing or carry
my purse and then lady who doesn't have
status says man I want to be like him
but I can't buy Kim so I buy the thing
that I've associated with Kim and then
when I wear it I'll have the status by
proxy from her and that's fundamentally
how the luxury Market works but it's
also how every Market works now why do
Brands drop celebrities when they make a
racial slur or they get into an accident
or they get arrested for fraud because
that becomes an association that people
do know and then they don't like and so
they say I don't want to associate our
with that and so they say we're going to
break this Association and so when
you're building a brand it's being very
particular about what and who you want
to associate with if I have a porn star
next to me and I have a porn star
co-host you're going to think very
different things about me even if the
material is exactly the same you might
be like that's flawed welcome to
humanity and psychology right doesn't
matter about whether it's flawed or not
I can just tell you that this is how it
works and so when you're building a
reputation especially in the bdb or the
BC space you want to provide value right
we talked about value creation earlier
and so it means that you want to give
things that people want you know fast
and easy way for them to consume that's
risk frea and so when we do that you
compound customer Surplus the street
word for that is Goodwill which is what
amount of value did someone get in
excess of what they paid for so let's
say I paid a doll for something and I
feel like I got $5 worth of value right
everything here between the two lines is
customer Surplus
or what we like to call Goodwill but the
interesting thing about this is that if
I do this over and over and over again
these things aren't additive in my
experience they've been multiplicative
meaning if I keep providing something
good and that's why it's so hard as a
brand to decide when do I want to
monetize something because the thing is
is that the next time you provide even
more value when people think that you're
going to monetize they love you that
much more and you get that much more
reach and more Goodwill so that the next
time and so it's basically reinvesting
but rather than reinvesting Capital
you're reinvesting Goodwill because what
I can tell you is that Goodwill
compounds faster than Revenue you can
build a100 million brand in 3 years and
to build $100 million in Revenue might
take you way longer than that and that's
because if you just focus on providing
Goodwill at scale you get a
disproportionate return The Rock was
able to overnight build teramana into a
6 bill billion dollar company simply
based on his brand and qu a beauty buil
her beauty line into a billion dollar
brand Conor McGregor with proper 12
billion dollar brand George Clooney
billion dollar brand and so they
understood this concept which is that
this will grow faster and so they
disproportionately invest early into
this so that later they can monetize and
do the right hook the big bloop to the
audience and to quote Uncle Warren it
doesn't matter how much Goodwill you
have any number
no matter how big it is multiplied by 0
equals z so if you make a bet in the
investing world that you then lose all
the money and you had 30 years of good
investing make and you go all in on one
bet and you lose you lose it all you
undo 30 years of good decisions with one
bad decision and that's the thing a lot
of people calculate when they think
about their personal brand if we're
going back to these flowers like I had
earlier if I have this one broken flower
it forever affects the way this bouquet
looks imagine you gave this to your wife
or your girlfriend and you said hey here
you go you'd be like it's such an
eyesore that it distracts from all the
other flowers that you have and so
that's why making sure that you never
risk your reputation to make the short
money so that you can let the Goodwill
keep compounding let the party keep
going is one of the smartest and hardest
long-term business decisions cuz believe
me if I start an only fans tomorrow I'll
bet you probably make a lot of money
it's like but it would be like this
broken flower and it would permanently
affect how people perceive it and the
brand that I also want to buil so now we
finished reputation and we're going to
talk about compounding one of those big
fancy words for investing about how to
get rich and stay richer compounding is
when something multiplies unto itself
all right so if I have a $100 and it
compounds at 10% a year next year it'll
be at $110 the year after that I add 10%
of this number which is on 121 right and
then the next year
133 and so forth and so you notice that
even though the time between these
intervals remain the same the actual
amount that we're growing continues to
rise proportionally to how much we have
which is how Uncle Warren can have a$1
billion and still make another $15
billion this coming year right is
because he understands the power of
compounding and they call it the eighth
wonder of the world and in the last
decade waren Buffet has made more money
than he made over the rest of his career
and that's because the longer you do it
the better it guess which is why some of
these early wealth building fundamentals
are so important compounding only
unlocks if you have a long-term
perspective because this early first
four years I mean decent but not bad but
if you do that over 30 years it becomes
unbelievable and it's also why you have
to not diversify because if we were then
splitting this up and saying you know
what maybe I'm going to stop this we're
interrupting the compounding process and
Equity is one of the single greatest
compounding Vehicles because you can
reallocate Capital within the same
vehicle right and a simple example of
that would be like if I have 10
locations and I can grow by
10% every month then I go from 10
locations to 11 locations and next month
I get 12 locations next month I get 13
and by my 20th month I can open two
locations I get to 22 then 24 and it
compounds because by that time you'll
built out the infrastructure ructure to
sustain a faster pace so Panda Express
they added 600 locations this year they
had
2,000 at the beginning of the year that
took them 45 years to get to this is one
year they grew more in this one
year than they did in any prior year
before that and that's why you just have
to stick with it for a long period of
time and this is one of the things that
people don't realize about restarting
when you go from year 10 to year 11 you
might be incredibly bored with your
business but if you go from 100 million
to 110 million you grew by 10 million
and even though this new thing might
sound more exciting in year 1 the liky
you go from 0 to 10 million year 1 is
really unlikely and so this is where all
of the compounding is unlocked even
though it's incredibly boring but if
there's one thing I can have you write
down boring is what makes you rich one
of my favorite codes for Charlie longer
is that the money isn't made in the buy
or the sell it's made in the weight and
the weight is the hardest part because
you have to sit with your hands in your
pockets and decide that the original
plan that you had was a good plan and
the hard part of the plan is sticking
with the plan not doing the plan like
deciding that you're going to work out
isn't hard deciding that it's going to
be 3 days a week for the year is it hard
it's continuing to do it for that entire
time is what makes it hard and I wanted
to find a term for you that has been
really helpful for me which is patience
right A lot of people like be patient be
patient what does that actually mean
being patient simply means needs
figuring out what to do in the meantime
is I make this video I being patient for
my stocks that are growing right now
while I'm making this video I'm being
patient for the cup that I want to lose
some fat while I'm making this video
right now I'm being patient for some of
our portfolio companies to capitalize on
the reinvestments that we're making
right now but I'm making a video and so
what you have to do is that when you
stick to the plan Sometimes the best
thing you can do is ignore and let it be
which means that you don't interrupt the
compounding process and there's a famous
study that studied patient and impulse
control and there's a one big learning
that I think all of us can learn from so
there was a test called the marshmallow
test they took little kids and they can
put a marshmallow in front of them and
they wait 30 minutes and then they can
eat the marshmallow now if they eat the
marshmallow during the 30 minutes they
didn't get a second marshmallow if they
able to wait 30 minutes and not eat the
marshmallow then they would give them a
second marshmallow at the end so they
got double the reward simply for waiting
30 minutes now what was interesting is
that they studied the difference between
the kids who could resist and the ones
who could and obviously long term they
figured out to the people who could wait
and delay gratifications the ones who
were more successful but the strategies
that they used to delay was not that
they stared at the marshmallow and used
their Whow the kids who were successful
did a number of different things some of
them went to a different side of the
room they just distanced themselves from
the marshmallow itself some of them
started singing songs to themselves
other of them took the marshmallow and
put it in their pocket so they couldn't
see it anymore and so so the big thing
is that they had the skills to figure
out what to do in the meantime and so
the more skilled you are the more ways
you can win and that's why building
skills is so important and it's so
important because it allows you to be
patient it gives you something to do in
the meantime while you allow your master
plan to come to fruition without
thinking that you're smarter than you
are to begin with so this concludes
almost the get rich for Die Trying sex
AK level three of wealth building so
let's oh wait Alex you laugh that b box
excellent observation that brings us to
the very last level which could even be
above the levels the level above the
levels on the business not in the
business you know what I'm saying enjoy
your W let's talk about it in my opinion
there are really just two levels of w
level one is that you have all of your
personal needs taken care of the second
level of wealth is the unlimited level
of wealth which is that you just always
want to keep using money to make more
money and that means that you've
progressed from solving your personal
needs to playing a game and so I think
what a lot of people is they can never
figure out what enough is for them and
there was a period in my life earlier on
where I was like okay let me figure out
all these rich people things I bought a
Bentley I was like let's go out to all
the nicest restaurants every single
night but the thing is is that to live
like the 1% it's actually not that
expensive if you fly private and it cost
about $50,000 per month if you want to
eat out every night of the week at the
nicest restaurants of you know $500
dinners every single night it's 15,000 a
month if you wanted to let's say lease a
Lamborghini or something payments are
probably 5 grand a month right on top of
that let's say you want to go and buy
designer clothing so that's another
$115,000 per month let's say you spend
$5,000 a month on a nutritionist and
another $55,000 a month on therapy and
performance coach whatever all right
let's just call it a cool $100,000 per
month of expenses oh we forgot to where
we live let's let's live something of
ball let's put another 50 Grand a month
on here so $150,000 a month is just
under $2 million a year in income now
that's after tax right so maybe close to
4 milon a year in income now that's a
good amount of money it's actually not a
lot in the massive scheme of things and
what I mean is that you can ball out all
the way balls to the wall for the rest
of your life on this level of income
what I would encourage you to do is
actually figure out what is good for me
maybe it's worth it to taste these
things and see which of them you
actually enjoy and I think it was really
doubtable for me to buy the belly and
realize I didn't care and then just I
gave it back 6 months later I sold it
back at a lost so I think the big tldr
here is that you need to figure out what
your personal dream list is and a lot of
people have these huge goals like I want
to be a billionaire it's like why
because you can just make this for the
rest of your life and ball out but real
real you can probably live incredibly
comfortably on $50,000 a month like
still 1% living unbelievable wealth
looking stuff for for $50,000 a month
after taxes so I think if you put what
does food look like right what does
travel look like what does clothing look
like what does experiences look like
what does Health look like and you start
putting an actual number to it you
realize that what you actually need to
satisfy your personal needs just to give
you less than you originally thought and
so that brings me to the next level of
this which is the game itself now
there's a reason that my podcast is
called the game and it's because at this
point I play the game because I enjoy
the game and so the whole concept of
enjoying your wealth is not about not
working and I think this is one of the
big myths you might feel that way now
because you hate what you do and the
fact that you hate what you do is one of
the reasons they might not ever get the
wealth you want and so it's not about
not
working it's about getting
addicted to
freedom and freedom again doesn't mean
you don't work it means you have the
option to work and so I believe that
humans are our best when we do work
that's worth doing when we have purpose
that we derive from the effort and the
toil that we put in every day and you
get weaker when you don't have an
opposing Force that's as strong as you
if you lift weights and you never lift
even close to your maximum you
eventually start losing muscle and I
think it's the same thing with mental
strength unless you're continually
raising the bar you eventually attri
it's use it or lose it and so most of us
want to become the best versions of
ourselves and in order to become the
best versions of ourselves we have to
increase the difficulty of the level
that we're playing on imagine playing a
game that You' beaten 100 times and then
you put it on the easiest level it gets
boring we think we want easier but we
don't we want to do things that we enjoy
more and enjoyment and easy are not
necessarily the same thing and so if
we're trying to enjoy our wealth it's
finding the things that we can lose
ourselves
in for the rest of our lives and being
okay with the fact that that thing May
shift over time in terms of what it
looks like or what it feels like and if
you fast forward all the way to the end
of the movie as a reminder you die and
you can't take any of it with you and so
even if you if you finish your life with
this big pile of money at the end you
still have to push it over the edge of
the
cliff right where it just falls off to
other people whose
hands are here because
you're
yeah and so
reminding myself of that fact every
single day reminds me that the whole
point of the game is to play the game
and by playing the game we win the game
because the best games in life and I'll
finish with this the best games in life
are infinite games not finite games and
I'll tell you the difference the point
isn't to get married the point is to
stay
married when it comes to business the
point isn't to win at business the point
is to stay in business and literally
keep playing
and so when we think about the greatest
games that we play as humans we have to
take this infinite frame or we fool
ourselves into a false finite prison
that we keep wondering why we don't feel
like we're winning when we get to the
Finish Line because we never realized
that there was no Finish Line to begin
with and the fact that we were playing
the game secured our Victory by its very
nature and so this realization helped me
reframe how I thought about spending my
time
so that I could enjoy my wealth the
point for me is to stay in business and
see who I can become in this process the
point is for me to see what does it look
like at 20 years of marriage with health
it's not that like cool I've been
training for 20 years I'm in decent
shape I wonder what it looks like when
I'm healthy at 50 because if you're only
in shape for 6 weeks of your life or 6
months of your life or even 6 years of
your life who cares if you only have a
good marriage for a few years of your
life who cares if you only in business
and then go out of business really
quickly and you get out of the game who
cares and which is why the biggest Hiway
that you can have and this is
from Winston chal you win as long as you
never quit and
so that's how you enjoy your life and
your wealth and there's your
blueprint